M it's
God it's
God up brothers so so we're going around
talking about Islam just trying to get
you guys opinion on on Jesus and what
you guys think about him would you guys
mind sharing your thoughts about
Jesus you believe Jesus as a m of God a
messenger of God
okay we don't believe that Jesus
coming back you believe he's coming back
okay to do to do
what to tell the truth for Christian
okay not this he didn't killed by
somebody for mistaken he wasn't
crucified and stuff yeah he didn't do
like that that's why he going to come
back before the day of judgment and he
going to clear the entire yeah everyone
going to know
the like even like Jesus believe Jes how
you guys believe a human being as a god
well so well we we actually believe that
God because he's all powerful he's able
to come to us even in a human form if he
chose to you know if he wanted to do
that he can and so that's just what we
te it's not that we don't believe God is
limited to where you can't do that you
know so so that that's what that is and
I just wonder and when you guys called
Jesus the son of God and who was the God
for his mother Mar so so this is what
the belief is is that God when he when
he came down in human form obviously he
created everything even Mary and so he
chose to be born through Mary through a
virgin birth so this is what he's it's
not that you know he had he slept with
Mary or anything nothing nothing
disgusting like that one question yeah
do you believe that God has a picture or
face or something like that no we don't
no so do you believe no no God is UN no
so that well that's that's interesting
because Muhammad kind of had this idea
that you know that does have like a a
face or like a hand or a shin
like Muhammad was was the one of the
prophets or Messengers and he's the last
and final messenger say and as we
believe Jesus and you guys who don't
believe him mhammad you believe Muhammad
I don't believe in not not as a prophet
not as a prophet I I haven't been I
haven't been convinced makes sense you
know we all believe the prophets and and
we believe and the last and final
messenger yeah was of Muhammad yeah so
all these people living this yeah that's
good last and final so so this is what
this is my thing is that cuz what you
love is like all the prophets taught the
same message right and so and so that's
that's what that that's a yeah that's an
important thing we are not surprising
for the coming of the Jesus because we
are not surprising at the coming of
prophet
Muhammad for the you know for the um
Duty that they they were assigned for
the humanity is um is one thing that
there is only one God and we should
follow One path and there's only one God
that's uh that's controlling all the
universe and creating all the humanity
and also as we accept the Jesus we
shouldn't be like surprised for the
coming of prophet Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam because all the prophets
that came they part of their Duty was
that they gave the um message and the
good news of coming of prophet Muhammad
s Alam one day that the prophet Muhammad
there will become a a person that they
complete all the religion and there is a
verse in Quran that says today I have
completed my religion for you and the
religion that I choose for you is Islam
so the Islam is as the as the message of
all the religions come with one duty
that says that there's only one God
that's that's we should we accept that
that has no uh companions no Partners
nothing no s that God doesn't need to
sleep doesn't needs to wife doesn't
needs to have like a son a no family let
me touch on that brother because you you
said some important things right that
about the continu the the continuation
of the prophets they all teach the same
thing and even that you know you're not
surprised about Muhammad's coming
because the previous Prophet said
Muhammad would come right and and so
I know that that's what the belief is in
Islam and now for me as a Christian I
believe everything that Jesus said right
so if Jesus said that you know somebody
like Muhammad would come I would believe
it so where would we where would I be
able to find this if I if I wanted to
see where did Jesus mention Muhammad
where would I find the Quran the Quran
is the best you know the complete um
Surah has that the Jesus and all
prophets said that um well and gives
this good news to all Humanity that the
one day this person will come you know
all the Jacob all the prophet that's
named and the other um spirituals
spirituals it said also in the Quran as
a complete uh completing that Al another
thing um and how there is like a lot
of
you the more you do research the more
you and Al to finalize my speech is that
is that um one thing that Jesus itself
never said and also in the Bible or in
any other spiritual that I am God but he
does but I am God okay so so let's let's
pause it cuz I want to get to this like
cuz this what's fascinating to me is if
the prophet said that Muhammad is coming
I have to believe in that I have to
believe Muhammad is a prophet if Jesus
said it I have to believe it so so so
this is my thing guys I know cuz the
verse that you're talking about is
chapter 61 I don't know that I forgot I
don't know the name of it but it's
chapter 61:6 where it says that Jesus
came with Glad Tidings confirming the
Tor and then he came saying he
confirming all not only the the
scriptures scriptures came
from exactly and then he says accept all
the prophet Prophet mam so so when he
says so when yeah but when he says I
came uh you know there's going to be a
messenger after that comes after me
named Ahmed right and so I'm like okay I
see that the Quran says this but where
can I find Jesus saying this you read
Quran you find but I have I have that's
what I'm saying I I see the verse it
claims he said it but I don't see like
more do your more
search thank you so much for okay well I
appreciate the conversation man much
take care of yourself yeah all
right so I we'll try to get somewhere
else but uh it doesn't seem like there's
maybe a reference outside of the Quran
I'll take one thank you
I don't think there's a reference
outside of the Quran that mentions uh
Jesus saying that ahed will come after
him uh so we have to end it there but
good conversation though so far
hopefully we can find somebody that has
that
answer this is
[Music]
good oh my God logic